a man accused of suddenly shooting a gun
inside a crowded Pennsylvania Walmart is
in a custody this morning five people
were shot police say the suspect drove
away with a woman and led officers on a
wild chase before he crashed into a
patrol car
Sarika Duncan is at the Cedarbrook Plaza
shopping center in win code outside of
Philadelphia where the chaos unfolded
last night Jericka good morning good
morning this Walmart remains closed with
the exception of employees which are
only allowed inside but you can imagine
the terror that those customers must
have felt as they rushed out yesterday
the Montgomery County SWAT team and 22
other departments responded 22 and among
those hospitalized a pregnant woman who
fell or trying to take cover from the
gunshots police rushed to this shopping
center in Winco Pennsylvania around 6:00
p.m. after an officer nearby saw droves
of people running out of the Walmart in
panic we just hear all these gunshots
all the employees running out they
crying in some people bleed and police
said the male suspect accompanied by
another woman got into a dispute with a
customer near the cash register words
were exchanged the male pulled the gun
from the females waistband and started
shooting the suspect allegedly fired at
least ten shots inside the crowded store
forcing those nearby
to take cover the Montgomery County SWAT
team made their way inside to secure the
area
come on baby the kids are there video
taken inside the Walmart shows anxious
customers trying to leave right after
the shooting the yarn suspect fled the
scene with his companion in a
light-colored Pontiac police chased them
for less than a mile along the way they
threw the gun from the vehicle and we
did recover the gun the car chase ended
after the male suspect who was driving
rear-ended a Philadelphia police car and
injured the two officers inside although
the suspects were arrested witnesses
were still left uneasy you would never
think that you would be at the point
that you might get killed or shot just
walking in a Walmart to do some shopping
three out of the six people injured were
Walmart employees police say that
according to hospital records the male
suspect was on some type of drugs and
it's still unclear right now as to
whether one of the victims had been
arguing with that male suspect Gail
very scary situation there thank you
Jericho